[Music]
rivalries are essential to any form of
competition and eSports is no exception
bad blood hype and history can help
create storylines that not only up the
ante on a single match but transcend
games and live on for years soap from
the iconic grudge matches to org pride
let's count down the top 10 rivalries in
eSports kicking off our list at number
10 is Team solomid and cloud 9 they're
the two most decorated franchises in na
and their head-to-head history is just
as impressive since c9 joined the NA LCS
in summer 2013 these two teams have met
in six out of 12 finals
[Applause]
in the playoffs and look at that they
are a team that works together and likes
each other that is the best team in
North America early on cloud 9 steam
first gameplay got the best of TSM but
then one particular Danish superstar
changed the course of the rivalry
forever
champions until 2018 both TSM and c9 had
never missed an opportunity to represent
North America at the World Championships
but someone's streak had to break we're
about to witness competitive league of
Legends history this is a chance to
redeem yourself in the eyes of the fans
for both and yet only one will have the
honor of doing so today it's one of the
most storied matchups in the NA LCS it
is the last chance to make it to the
World Championship it's cloud 9 vs TSM
it was there were c9 with best bjergsen
as they locked in their slot at Worlds
and broke TSM streak of playing in every
World Championship
[Applause]
this side this one
three Oh
[Applause]
coming in at number nine are mango and
Armada a rivalry that's unfolded over
nearly a decade of competitive super
smash bros melee and become a
foundational faceoff that moved the game
itself forwards I think they're a really
good rivalry in the sense that they they
both represent different styles of play
in the game Armada focuses more on you
know the optimal stuff just by the tech
took what you're supposed to do and
that's how you're gonna win we're mango
represents the site of the game with
endless like possibilities going into
Genesis in 2009 mango was the United
States best Smasher while Armada was a
young upstart from Europe a region with
zero competitive presence the two met in
the finals paving the way for their
future rivalry two years later just
before melees explosive growth Armada
and mango faced off in the Genesis two
grand finals but this time Armada took
the upper hand
[Applause]
Armada even it up with that wind but by
the time melees resurgence hit in 2013
the pair were neck and neck facing off a
game in a game for the top spot at
plenty of tournaments right I think I
won the first time you win the second
time and now we're here everybody asked
and even Smash fan they'll tell you that
they want name or monogram this will be
the tiebreaker fans in the United States
might cheer from mango but no one really
took a side both players were so good
that they advanced melees metagame and
viewership with every insane set they
played Armada has since retired and
mango has talked about refocusing on his
streaming career but their rivalry ends
with a nearly even match record and two
evil World Championships apiece
winning evo 2017 from winners
congratulations to my man like I said no
one has worked harder and a hug of
respect between these two fierce
competitors our number eight spot goes
to the rivalry that propelled halo to
the top of the North American eSports
world 2006 marked the height of Halo 2
which was a game dominated by two of the
most electrifying teams in eSports
history final boss and carbon with the
ogor twins and Walshy final boss spent
the last year brushing aside every team
they faced that was until a group of
young upstarts that went by team carbon
challenged their throne
final boss and carbon met in the
national championship finals in 2005 as
team 3d and team freaks then again in
2006 and 2007 as well as six other major
finals final for 2007 Boost Mobile MLG
pro circuit champions $100,000 richer
and even more importantly those guys
redeemed for last season's collapse
while final boss would go on to be the
most dominant team in halo history
Karpin showed us that even the greatest
of all time can be beaten
Cinderella story games
in the world of dota 2 perhaps no
rivalry is as ubiquitous as number 7 on
our list China versus the West China was
seen as the dominant nation in the
original DotA's competitive scene and
that aura of excellence carried over
into dota 2
yeah China was the be-all end-all like
there was there was no one that was able
to stand up to them but the Chinese were
also very secretive they never even
released their replays for six months
after a game was played just out of fear
that some will be able to see their
strategies and analysed them deep in in
high detail but the West was always
there to keep them in check with their
distinct style of play with na vi's win
at ti1
some fans might have thought China had
fallen off but they quickly bounced back
in dominating fashion with AI G's win at
ti2
[Applause]
as the International continued over the
years a pattern known as the cycle arose
where winning teams would alternate
between Western and Chinese each year up
until 2018
[Applause]
including the most recent di seven out
of eight international grand finals have
been China versus the West with the West
currently leading with a four and three
head-to-head record and number six we've
got what a lot of people considered to
be eSports first big rivalry vu versus
fatality back in the days of quake
eSports vu was a European star and one
of the fanatics first big names
associated with the org while fatality
was known as the greatest gamer in the
world at the time
the town is the best in the world who is
undisputed the best PK player
of all time these two competitors blew
their rivalry during the era of quake
and into painkiller where they faced off
in seven out of nine grand finals we've
seen this matchup how many times about
200 over the course of this 12-month
World Tour and it's about to happen
again this is the highly anticipated
game that everyone loves to watch and
everyone's come to love receiving is
almost every single event boom fatality
of city's biggest rival or 80 sports of
the MOA and this time it takes on a
whole new twist with $150,000 up for
grabs
he's to set the tone for what a lot of
great gaming rivalries look like now
down there Jim coming in at number five
we've got a historic counter-strike
rivalry SK gaming vs. fnatic a very very
good strong grenade coming in there
Wally and Carmel exchange to now Forrest
will pick up the hat trick to put fnatic
into the grand final here in Dubai
they beat SK these two organizations go
back to the very beginnings of Counter
Strike and have become two of the game's
most decorated franchises major
championship in a row
over the years many players including
get right Forrest Olaf and fallen have
passed between the two teams and had it
fuel to the fire that was already raging
from their matches on the game's biggest
stages one of them the next go to take
the last kill of the game 66 in favor of
SK Cadiz they make it through to the
playoffs
it almost feels like in any arab cs you
could pit fnatic against SK and all eyes
would be on this rivalry and it's one
that eventually bled into League of
Legends as well fnatic vs. SK gaming
goes back many many years you're aware
of that story driver yeah we're players
become p.m. for like two years they know
each other
Daigo and justin wong are among the
fighting game communities oldest rivals
and represented the west struggle
against Japan's dominance in the early
days of fighting games that's why it
comes in at number four on our list but
these two have been playing each other
for so long this has been the classic
America versus Japan rivalry Justin and
Daigo have faced off countless times in
plenty of games but no match has ever
been more iconic than their evo 2004
losers finals match now known as Evo
moment 37
[Applause]
Daigo had long been considered one of
the best fighting game players in the
world
well Justin Wong North America's
wunderkind had often played the role of
challenger their lifetime record is
relatively even but every time they face
off in Street Fighter 4 Street Fighter 5
that's gonna be one date for justin wong
or even Marvel vs. Capcom 3 bullying a
standard bullying we need a spirit bomb
right now it's guaranteed to be hype
Justin and Daigo have been going
head-to-head for more than a decade now
and with both of them still at the top
of their games we'll likely see many
more matches between them for years to
come and Justin must admit that was an
excellent match as the crowd is on its
feet 2009 guru Mahara the Japanese
legends
the place is afraid
hold up Justin walk when we think of
Call of Duty eSports it's hard not to
think of the rivalry between optic
gaming and faze clan which is why it
comes in at number three on our list
this shot-caller in a 1v2 39 seconds
remaining Kravitz gotta get finished
phase we'll take your season 3
championship phase and optic didn't just
clash on the competitive stage that
rivalry started on YouTube where both
organizations were forces in creating
Cod content
[Music]
at the eSports level these two teams
both saw their fair share of success but
even though optics competitive
reputation developed much earlier than
phases phase always played optic tough
and that is it babes gonna win your
summer 100k championship for gfinity a
massive comeback down 3-1 overall in the
series that is a shocking comeback right
there look like off the gaming and
complete control and then face just the
momentum too strong there at the end and
when eights joined phase one of the most
heated rivalries in eSports history
reached its peak what did you do to
change things here this tournament I
mean I really didn't do anything I mean
it's kind of fell a point for me after
we the optic at Columbus and I mean I
don't say anything got boring but I was
just kind of focusing on other things
but I mean coming to this event the
World Championships caught up biggest
event of the year definitely something I
want to get my second ring in you know I
have two more than a chop when a young
pro gamer named flash made his
professional debut in 2007 many fans
felt that we had already seen the
highest level of StarCraft brood war
play but the transcendent skills of
flash pushed that game to levels no one
had thought possible
Oh
and no one was able to push flash to his
absolute best more than Jaedong which is
why this rivalry comes in in the
runner-up spot on our list flash is the
most dominant player in the history of
StarCraft the last player to be named
bonds wha but when he did lose more
often than not it was at the hands of
Jaden the de-facto best served player in
the world this has been nicknamed the
dream final so many players have been
waiting up for a final such as this one
with two people who just seemed to be
unbeatable
last he said move out fast he knows that
he's attacking now but you can see Jay
dunk just has too many muta there it is
the game
Jaina blows out the person matches
between these two Titans drew fans
across the world back to a game that
some had begun to feel was stagnating
and helped to make late-era brood war
arguably the greatest time to be a
Starcraft fan
we are
people's although yes totally put on a
burner you can I come to capitulate
perhaps no rivalry in eSports has pushed
a game as far as flash versus jaedong
and even today almost a decade later
their matches still send shivers down
our spines has made history once again
by coming out getting the golden mouse
beating the best Cirque in history and
taking the double title msl OSL in the
same season when you think of the
biggest rivalry ever your mind
immediately wanders to the biggest names
on the biggest stage
no single rivalry in eSports exemplifies
those two things more than the telecom
wars and that's exactly why SK Telecom
t1 vs kt rolster comes in at number one
on our list a rivalry so long lasting
and important that it dates back to the
early days of StarCraft
after StarCraft their league of legends
rivalry began with a bang when SKT
bested KT in the OGN champions summer
final in 2013 after which SKT became the
most dominant team in league history
because we really are witnessing you
know the birth of a dynasty here three
times in four years is nothing to
Scotland and while SKT are ahead in
their head-to-head record kt rolster
will be attending world's 2018 as
Korea's number one seed while SKT will
be watching from the sidelines
[Music]
[Applause]
the beach in busan four years ago New
York is the fourth unique champion in
lck history well guys that's our take on
the top ten rivalries in eSports now if
you like this video I'm gonna bet you're
gonna like story of Nikko that's right
we're giving the bosnian csgo superstar
the full story of treatment and that's
this Saturday so make sure you have
notifications turned on for that thanks
for watching if you want more great
content just like this be sure to hit
the subscribe button
[Music]
you